[Music]
[Music]
after the battle of 2020
crowder readies before the legions of
big tech apply
our mug club warriors are outnumbered
and exhausted
but it is not fear that grips them only
a heightened sense of things
cool air in their lungs the winds
sweeping the plugs which stand atop the
head
of the professed victor the former vice
president and would-be king sits atop
his throat
as he speaks to an undefeated foe
prouder despite your insufferable
arrogance
the god-king has come to admire your
fighting spirit and your
mugs you could make a mighty ally
man even in light of your continued
insults
your horrid hate speech blasphemy the
lord of hosts
is prepared to forgive all and more
to reward your service
you you fight for your channel man keep
it
you fight for your whole thing keep them
too
your victory will be complete if you but
lay down your
arms and kneel before your holy former
vice president
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
this
you